[Music]
the Jeselnik and Rosenthal vanity
project junior vice president we're
gonna start the news with my favorite
story to come across the NFL wires in a
long time and that was Bills cornerback
Vontae Davis deciding to retire at
halftime he pulled himself out of the
game just went up to the coaches he
started the game played 29 snaps in the
first half and according to Bill's coach
Shawn McDermott just told them he was
done put on his street clothes got in
his car and left left the stadium right
away he said he meant no disrespect to
his coaches and teammates he just he
just thought it was time to end his
career I'd have time how do you feel
about that like I said a lot of players
saying was the most disrespectful thing
they've ever seen how did you how like
how do sports journalists feel about it
are they like just kind of laughing at
are they upset with him they think it's
a weak move it's one of those stories
that's annoying cuz everyone has the
exact same take which is just how could
he do that you know that's that's the
worst thing that you could possibly do
it's so disrespectful to your teammates
and I understand that but I I kind of
almost just felt bad because to be in
the mental space that he had to be in to
quit at halftime probably was not a fun
fun thing there's a reason why no one
quits during a game it's sure like that
that's a pretty almost difficult thing
to do to have to just say bye see ya
absolutely my only problem with it I've
seen all these takes of I guess
disrespectful it's awful you got to be
with your team whatever the team doesn't
care about the player and if he handled
it differently but like coach I'm hurt
and then after the game done it no one
would have cared or just like half-ass
the second half of the game which plenty
of people would have done yeah my only
problem is that he changed industry
clothes before he left I think you want
to walk out of there full uniform with
the pads because they're not gonna get
him back they're not gonna send somebody
to your house and again my dream would
be to quit and just leave in the middle
of a show Anthony
Anthony I'm still here see that this is
that that was me wanting to show you
what a terrible actor Greg is because
Greg could not pull that off it like you
would think like oh we did his Anthony
still there and then when soon as Greg
opens his mouth I think let's do it with
late if you tell me tell me you wanna it
it has always been my dream to quit at
the halftime of a podcast correct Greg
what Greg Greg who are you
Antonio Brown has been in the news all
week first he got into a sideline our
altercation or just argument with his
coaches and then on Monday
a former Steelers PR guy sent a tweet
out saying that Antonio Brown needs to
thank his lucky stars because he was
drafted by a team that had been and been
got a be paid and Antonio Brown quote
retweeted that and just responded trade
me let's find out and of course everyone
went a little nuts Antonio Brown also
didn't show up to work on Monday which
is they you know they get treatment they
have meetings wasn't there it's unclear
whether it was excused or not his agent
says he does not want to be traded but
he put that out there on social media
trade me let's find out what do you
think of your team falling apart so
early in the season I mean it's it's
it's actually kind of I'm not I wouldn't
say it's a joy I expect us to fully
rebound and win the Superbowl but it
does kind of take the pressure off of
being a fan of seeing Le'Veon kind of
holdout in Antonio getting up soon I
think Antonio be getting a lot more
touches if if Flavian was out there so I
understand many ways he was targeted 17
times in the game how many more times
can they throw the ball at him 18 Greg
18 and higher in fact any number higher
than 17 question oh yeah but wide
receivers were all nuts like remember
when Jerry Rice said he wasn't getting
enough respect after the Super Bowl when
they named him MVP he's like that and
Antonio Brown can do whatever he wants
he cuts his hair like he's daring you to
say something he smiles like he's never
had anything stuck in
teeth before the man runs routes like
it's the only way to get into heaven and
that the Steelers ever traded him over a
tweet I jump off the tallest cliff in
Los Angeles and right before I hit the
ground I'd scream free skydiving lessons
why would that be it that you said but
what would what would be what what why
would that be what you said free
skydiving lessons that is the funniest
thing you can yell if you jump to your
death around other people if you were
standing there and someone fell to death
right in front of you right before they
fell they yelled free skydiving lessons
you would not be able to stop laughing
that is the absolute funniest thing you
could yell that jumping to your death I
think it would confuse a lot of people
yeah but in a funny way Erika back me up
but you would never know you would never
know would you what do you mean I mean
you would never know the reaction that
it got no but it wouldn't land it you
would know you would hear about it in
heaven but if anyone can think if anyone
if any of the viewers can listeners can
think of something funnier to yell when
he jumped your death and free skydiving
lessons then please please let me know
but I've thought about this a lot for
years and I finally gotten to use it
with this Antonio Browns story
[Music]
you